right new video 15 minutes again I've
got the default late can some player
from Ukraine check with Liam it doesn't
have a name in them all right I'm trying
to play the con variation here fee not
quite sure what is it going for c3 or
something I intend to play a 6 here on
94 the con variation discuss this
recently with a friend of mine and he
intends to play this line so maybe I
give it a try as well okay so
surprisingly i'm taking his time here
all right yeah e 6 & a 6 is the con
variation it's a pretty pretty
interesting setup and the main point is
that it's a very flexible line black has
still the option of using his bishop for
instance exactly now I could play Bishop
before here white is going for this
ignition text set up and I have the
chance now to to get this pin going here
and now i can even play d5 putting on
immediate pressure on his center unless
oh yeah I don't think no I was just
thinking maybe white has some ideas with
a three and maybe sacrificing this pawn
here but I don't think this is Sir to
feasible not quite sure what is playing
here really the Khan variation actually
should should prevent the English attack
so he went for it anyway and I hope this
is really the yeah the refutation or the
reason why the english attack is not
possible I'm not a you chure expert here
I only know that against the Carnot
shouldn't be possible but i'm not sure
about the exact line that this looks
looks very logical getting immediate
pressure on c3 and now with d5 played
also on the center here so if white
would capture i capture with the night
and then see three years
the huge huge pressure I've got a
detector each arms already and he
doesn't have a convenient way to to
defend this night he would yeah probably
need to to do something drastic yeah
yeah this actually allows a five and
deform I don't think white should have
any great sacrifices here if I've and d4
should should win a piece i'm not
mistaken here you five yeah maybe you
can get some kind of semi correct
compensation out of this but yeah but
well it's a piece i could have caused
some also just kept on you form with a
nice position but okay he 5t forwards a
piece hard to believe that that white
should should have enough there he can
play something like 90 to d4 then let's
say 94 ed for Bishop before it's got two
points than form for the piece but it's
hard to believe that this should be
enough
yeah you could also take on on d5 with
the pawn and then ed for Bishop t4 and
sucking a piece this way okay deform and
it's a piece
and I still need to be on a bit cautious
because of course I'm not so so well
developed but ok it shouldn't be too
serious I also right now need to think
on how to how to develop further here 96
some is the the usual move I think to to
win a tempo here of course it could take
on f6 but this would weaken now the dark
squares really am enormously and he
always has the Queen Indus in this
annoying pin you know this is good I
think if he retreats I just won a nice
tempo for for development and if he
takes I ok I would capture and if he
goes for a long castle for instance I
can just play this should be six he
always suffers from this pin and not
quite sure how he should should proceed
with this pin any way to to get rid of
it ok he just retreated the bishop
question always so should I am
complete development first or should I
try to to play a concrete museum like
let's say 95 with the idea of night c4
just capturing you should eat six of
course I need to reckon with a 4 at some
point
yeah bishop it 60 looks normal still
here come on let's try to not play too
slowly here on f4 I could also consider
putting a look on the 8th with long
castle law all right
yeah yes I have more than one one good
move here I could also keep it simple
and just capture c3 and play Queenie
five which exchanges queens are or
winter an additional porn on be too yeah
it's certainly not bad of course I can
also just keep the pin with my bishop a
five maybe you treat the Bishop to b6
later to exchange in three the three
bishop is some somewhat yeah maybe it's
a it is the best piece in a way
okay maybe this would have been simpler
i'm not sure but it's a field strange to
give up the bishop / voluntarily
uh-huh
okay maybe before is this idea but I
could play 95 now for instance applying
a pressure on c3
yeah he cannot go before c3 is just
hanging and I'm threatening to take
there anyway i guess some yeah short
castle would be the would be the normal
move but if he cancels short i think
i've got the nice move Knight to g4 yeah
if you would have canceled short I could
have played nazi for can show this
afterwards quickly it's a quite nice
tricular ok what now I can just take c 3
is there some some brilliant trick here
takes takes Queen takes and if you move
the king i can take take the 3 yard so
does nothing especially ok let's just
wrap the material
so if you play some Bishop to d2 I could
also well I can take on d3 was checked
see a CD 23 and it should be yeah it's
just winning but I could also play Queen
D 3 CD night x check and exchange down
to an end game with an complete extra
piece queen d 3 does he have some some
brilliant move then he has some Queen
move maybe Quincy five Quincy five form
but then I can just play 97 or go into
g3 but then I could play Queen D for
this should just trade down to a an
ending with an extra piece
yeah now I can just just cover the five
night I think Quinn deform but what
about Knight takes e4 this also possible
Knight takes e4 it takes you five of the
Queen I have Queen d2 Queen have to mate
if it takes d3 I can take on g3 in the
Queen and it's just completely winning
does it does he have something else if
not then this is just just completely
over it's got no checks or something
this should work
takes on e4 can exchange on the g3 em
yeah okay
yeah this should really end this unless
he wants to continue with the piece down
in the end game
yeah really no move
alright so i can just take the two so
and this is two extra pieces oh wow he
continues white resides okay he doesn't
continue yeah two weeks two pieces this
is a bit much yeah this was a really
unreal opening disaster but I wanted to
show you quickly as a nice nice one if
he if he doesn't take doesn't play crook
see one here but castles I'm not quite
sure how do i I can I can take some
moves back here if he canceled so now I
have this nice trick this is quite funny
threatening made on h2 so it doesn't
have much choice he needs to capture the
night night takes and still this made
threat here so he needs to move the
Queen and maybe yes maybe maybe he's got
Bishop f4 maybe Bishop before my idea
was if it if he moves the Queen now I
can take on a three note that see 7s
cavity of the bishop and if he
recaptures now then this one just wins
wins the Queen nice little line but
maybe he's got to do some maybe he's got
it should have for him and this isn't so
so brilliant I mean okay this uh this is
of course good for black but it's not
not an instant when he needs to take
then i can i can grab the exchange here
and now white is got them a pawn for the
exchange i have black is better but it's
um it's not winning not directly winning
so now g4s it's not so strong at I as I
thought yeah okay I can just just play a
normal move look look something da door
castles like us appear so this kind of
opening here is not really really
playable he needs to to do some yeah
damage control like a three or something
yeah this kind of kind of setup is not
playable for white this English attack
setup is not playable against the this
e6e 6 a-6 line the current variation
white white needs to continue on
normally here and like yeah I think this
is this is also already unusual i think
what usually placed should eat you or we
should be three here or f for something
like this yeah maybe you can he can go
push up d three or something here
develop develop some pieces and this
this instantly goes into the spin and
it's already a bit problematic yeah
thanks for watching see you soon with a
new video